What's up gamers? It's time for twitchcon
2018 epic cringe compilation
I got a couple uh...
Hopes, I got a couple of guesses. I think there's gonna be there's gonna be dabbing
What did I teach you the micro dab guys? Come on, Michael? Yes! Yes you, yes, beautiful!
I think there's gonna be some pretty
Lit
Fortnite dances
But most importantly, there's going to be...
I think of myself as like above the average person. I think of myself as like above the average person
Oh god
No, there's no good way to say this; I think of myself as like above the average person
So I don't feel like many people could relate to me
*Disgust*
I know you guys are gamers, so I got something special for you; the Elgato HD60S
This baby lets you capture in 1080p 60 frames per second. What else do you want baby? A-all irony aside
I-I've been using Elgato since the beginning of my youtube career
They're always on the top and I'm proud to have them as a sponsor
I'm even more proud because now I have my very own design. Thank you Elgato, very cool. Honestly, that is pretty epic
so basically you can plug this into your
Xbox, your Playstation. I you can use it to record with your phone,
iPad, all these kinds of things. It's the best way to do it
I guarantee you. If you're looking for a way to record video or a gameplay footage check out the Elgato 60S. Thank you
Very cool. Let's go on for the video
First of all, I really enjoyed the the Ninja roast, you know
A lot of the people here that are here in front of us are our viewers
Which is what actually amazes me about Utama that you're up here because most your viewers are outside because of the age restriction
*Laughs* *Cheers*
Damn that was a sick roast
I love how the audience just... apparently it's the greatest thing yet. No one's ever heard
*Clap* *clap* *clap*
I don't know why the audience treats like yeah, it was a it was a roast
Okay, I'm not gonna deny that. It was a roast and I appreciate it. But the audience reaction is just so mismatched this guy.
Oh my god, this audience are dicks.
Shroud apparently won a competition. That was pretty epic
Hey, first of all
Thank you everybody for coming out today. This was amazing. We're so excited to have everybody and what an amazing tournament from you guys
So on behalf of the Doritos brand we are proud to present the Doritos Bowl trophy to team Shroud
Let's give it up for team Shroud
They are your very first Doritos Bowl champions
They put in the work, they put in the time
I don't know why this is so funny
The Dorito Bowl champion combined with this music that's an epic moment. I can only imagine
putting countless hours into video games for this moment to get the Dorito Bowls
Championship
"Hi"
I always wonder, you know who's watching these streams but things start to make sense when you watch these conventions
A lot of things make sense
what a gentleman, you know, then put his slob on her back why bother with the hand if you're not even gonna
You know, I don't get it. How does you know?
I'm the most awkward handshake person in the world, but you'll that catch me dead before I use a hand hover
I don't get it. You can't mess that up. At least. How do you mess that up? It's literally impossible.
*Music and "Kids?" Dancing*
I get it, you know, it's just kids dancing. It's fine. You can't really go: ahh it's so cringe!
Everyone dances as a kid and it's an epic cringe, but the thing I don't understand is why are they people watching it?
Look at that, why are there literally hundreds of people watching this?
And then this stan shows up, the god of a Fortnite dance shows up
Look at that child hahaha. Everybody, please give it up for the Fortnite dance crew make some noise.
I just realized that we have this-a similar name
Do they just forget to go on stage are there there? Okay
So confused everything is this confuses me I feel so old
Why do I feel so old I don't want to be like this guys, please
Someone save me, make me enjoy things again. Fortnite, everything is just killed me
Oh yeah, this is my dance!
Oh yeah
Now that's epic
Okay, I feel like knowing the Fortnite dance's at this point is the equivalent of knowing how to knowing how to breathe apparently every
Kid ever has just studied in front of the mirror how to do the dance
You know that anyone that knows the fortnight dance deliberately took time to watch up go to online to watch a fortnight dance
Tutorial to make sure that they can follow the movement so that they can do the dance as well
But unless you know this dance don't even talk to me, okay?
I'm not sure if this is twitch calm, but it's a beautiful clip grab this
Uh
Black Monster right here. That's right. I don't know why we call it that
I'm gonna have a, you hear that cracking open a cold one Duncan. You got a problem
Do you like the test of that Black Monster?
Let's just go to the game this is getting out of control
What just happened there?
No hug. Thank you very much. This is me at any convention. Okay, no physical contact we talked about this
I don't want to end up in a cringe compilation. Okay? No hugs. No nothing
This guy knows what's up, and I can respect that dammit
You just dodged a bullet right there very easy
I mean
Why would you hug if you're on camera what an idiot get new friends that guy. Well if you guys didn't know his actual first
name is Dick
Which it must be tough being named after your favorite celebrity body part that go after to gain popularity
Drake
Marshmallow, Mark Cuban who's next?
Hey
I mean I only lag like at a few spots
Yeah, I do you want my backpack
You'll have to come to my room to get it though. I
Think it's a win-win but you know. What? Heh, I'm just jokeing!
Okay, it's a joke
*Laugh*
I think it's a win-win, I can't believe I just said that
"It was a joke! It was a joke guys!" I think poco laws. You gave me like a little clip.
Yeah
You wanted me to show of like, your channel
-working on in my team
Put the wrong video, I don't know what this is
I'm so sorry. I'm really I've never seen that video before
That was such an epic, gnome
And these people don't even know the gnome meme. This is me when I try and make fun of people and they don't understand
And then this is unfunny and uncomfortable. Yeah
No one knows how to react that was cool I guess
I don't know what just happened
That's how you know your life you're sober if you ever get genomed it's time to pack your baggage say, goodbye
You might as well start digging Your Grave it's over. Then of course we get to the
*Clap*
The greatest cliff of all time the man that decided to summarize the mind of every twitch streamer on this platform
Let's just jump into it
don't feel like many of my viewers should relate themselves to me because and this is like super like kind of like
Like God like kind of weird is like I do think of myself as better than or not better but like bigger
There's no good way to say this I think of myself as like above the average person so I don't feel like many people could
Relate to me as like bad as that sounds I know
But like that's just genuinely how I- (Lord have mercy on your soul)
I think that what makes this clip so great is that he knows he's not supposed to say it. He's like
Ugh
it's really no good way to say this but
I'm basically God I'm basically better than everyone else low key- like god complex. Just stop right there if you're ever in that moment
Don't cross the border. I mean I shouldn't be talking about this at all. Actually, nevermind
I just love how you know, you're a streamer. You're the kind of person that relies on donations from other people
You're basically begging other people for money and that's how you make a living. But uh you're so better than the average person
You're still uh you're still above the average person. I'm gonna go on a limb and say no. No you're not
You're 100% not better than the average person and anyone that think they're better than the average person
Is 100% not better than the average person if he just said it as a meme instead of hesitating and be like, you know
What I just think I'm better than the average person
I don't think anyone would care. But the fact that he was sort of hesitating being like, oh, this is kind of weird
There's no good way to say this
Uh
But uh yeah, I'm better. I'm better. This has been twitch con 2018 epic cringe moment
I hope you gamers enjoyed it if you did consider smashing like and subscribing
We're trying to hit the sixty nine million subscribers for forty series. Can we make it happen guys? And
yeah, just you know what to do and as always
Goodbye!!!
*subtitles by forevarockzz and eva!*
*have a nice day everyone*
*what are you still doing here?*
*smash the subscribe button*
*we gotta win this war 9y/o*
Have a good rest of your day!